♪ [music] ♪
- [male] We are the paradoxical ape,
bi-pedal, naked, large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools and language but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly, we hand
down knowledge, we empathize and deceive,
we shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Edward] Okay, so I wanted to first
thank the organizers really for this kind
invitation to join this cast of stellar
thinkers about the biology and behavior of
language. I actually want to switch the
title a little bit to something more
specific I want to talk to you about
organization in particular a kind of
organization that I refer to as a
taxonomy. And the organization that I am
actually really referring to is the
organization of sound and particular
speech sounds and how those are actually
processed in a very important part of the
brain called the superior temporal gyrus
also known as Wernicke's area.
The main focus of my lab is actually to
understand the basic transformation that
occurs when you have an acoustic stimulus
and how it becomes transformed into
phonetic units. In other words, basically
, how do we go from the physical stimulus
that enters our ears into one that's
essential a mental construct one that's a
linguistic one. And to basically ask the
simple question, “What is the structure of
that kind of information as it's processed
in the brain?” Now this actually turns out
to be a very complex problem because it's
one that actually arises from many levels
of computation that occur in the ascending
auditory system, as sounds actually come
through the ears they go up through at
least seven different synaptic connections
across many different parts of the brain
even bi-laterally to were they're actually
processed in the non-primary auditory
cortex in the superior temporal gyrus. And
what we know about his area from animal
studies and non-human primates for example
is that this is an area that no longer is
tuned to basic low level sound features
like pure tones, pure frequencies but in
one that is actually tuned to very broad
complex sounds.
There have been very nice work in fMRI
that's actually demonstrated that this
area is far more selective to complex
sounds like speech over non-speech sounds.
So the basic question is not really about
where is this processing going on, the
question is how. Okay, what is the
structure of information in this
transformation that's going? And in
particular, what kind of linkages can we
make between that physical stimulus and
the internal one, which is a phonetic one?
For me, I think it's really important to
acknowledge some really important
fundamental contributions that occur that
give us some insight and put them in a
very important perspective.
For me, I think one of the most important
pieces of work that led to this work that
I'm about to describe from our lab was
actually 25 years ago using an approach
that's actually far more complicated and
difficult to achieve than what we do in
our own work. This is using single unit
and single neuron recordings that were
recorded from patients that were
undergoing neurosurgical procedures for
their clinical routine care and this very
extremely rare but precious opportunity,
to actually record from certain brain
areas while someone is actually listening
to speech. And these are from my close
colleague and mentor Dr. Ojemann who's in
the audience today. But why I think it's
so important to acknowledge this work is a
lot of the clues about what I'm about to
describe were actually seen 25 years ago.
And this figure that's extracted from that
paper where they actually showed and could
record from single brain cells called
neurons in the superior temporal gyrus
that they were active and corresponding to
very specific sounds. But if you actually
look at where those sounds are,
they're not exactly corresponding to the
same exact. . . let's say phonemes or the
same exact sounds. But in fact, they are
corresponding to a class of sounds. This
was an observation that was made in this
paper and they thought that perhaps this
is some mention of phonetic category
representation there. But it wasn't that
clear, actually, and there are a lot of
other really important observations that
were made in that paper. Now from a
linguistic perspective in thinking about
how behaviorally we organize this
information in the brain, there's actually
a wonderful way to approach it, it's not
perfect but a very wonderful way to think
about how languages across the world
actually share a similar and shared
inventory of speech sounds.
Not all completely the same, each language
has a different numbering, but they highly
overlap and the reason why they overlap is
because they are produced by the same
vocal tract. And this is essentially like
a periodic table of sound elements for
human language and speech. And so, this
table actually has two really important
dimensions the horizontal dimension is
actually one that we call the place for
articulation, it's referencing where in
the vocal tract these sounds are made for
example, bi-labial sounds the P and the B
require you to actually have a transient
occlusion at the lips, 'ba.' You cannot
make those sounds without that particular
articulatory movement. Some of the other
sounds like a 'Da' or a 'D' or a 'T' a
'Da' a 'Ta' a 'Da' we call alveolar
because the front of the tongue tip is
actually placed against the teeth. And so,
these are actually referencing where
occlusions are occurring in the vocal
tract when we speak and those actually
correlate necessarily to very specific
acoustic signatures. The other dimension
is what we call the manner of articulation
and so the manner of articulation is
actually telling you a little bit more
about the not so much where, but how in
the vocal tract the constrictions are made
in order to produce those sounds.
We have certain ones like plosives where
you have complete closure of the vocal
tract and then transient release. Other
sounds where you have near complete like a
fricative like, 'sha,' 'za' those sounds
that we call fricative. And if you
actually look at vowels, they actually
have a similar structural organization,
there actually is something that actually
references where in the vocal tract either
front, middle or back, or the degree of
open and closure. So for both consonants
and vowels there actually is a structure
that we know about linguistically and
phonologically about how these things are
organized.
I think the thing that interests me is
that, like I referenced before, that this
is something like a periodic table is that
there is something fundamental about these
units to our ability to perceive speech.
And these phonological representations are
not necessarily the ones that we think of
as these letters that we call phonemes,
but actually groups of phonemes that share
something in common; what we call
features. And these are the members of
small categories which combine to form the
speech sounds of human language. This
became very attractive to me as a model of
something that look for in the brain
because of essentially why it could be so
important; is that languages is actually
do not vary without limit but they
actually reflect some single or limited
general pattern which is actually rooted
in both the physical and cognitive
capacities of the human brain. And I would
add the vocal tract. And this is a very
not a new kind of thinking but it's one
that has not been clearly elucidated in
terms of its biological mechanisms.
So in order for us to get this
information, it requires a very special
opportunity, the one where we can actually
record directly from the brain. And in
many ways, this is actually a lot more
coarse than the kind of recordings that
were done almost 25 years ago.
These are ones from electrode sensors that
are placed on the brain in order to
localize seizures in patients that have
epilepsy. In the seven to 10 days that
they are usually waiting to be localized,
we have a very again, precious opportunity
to actually have some of the participant,
the patient volunteers listen to natural
continuous speech. Look at those neural
responses on these electrode recordings to
see how information is distributed in the
superior temporal gyrus when they're
listening to these sounds. This gives you
a sense of actually what that neural
activity pattern looks like.
[audio example]
We're going to slow down that sentence a
lot here.
- [audio example] Ready tiger, go to green
five, now.
- So you can see that the information is
being processed in a very precise both
spatial and temporal manner in the brain,
and this is exactly the reason why this
kind of information has been elusive,
because we do not currently have a method
that actually has a both spatial and
temporal resolution and at the same time
covers all of these areas simultaneously.
And so, it's again in the context of these
rare opportunities with a human patient
volunteers that we can conduct this kind
of research. So the natural question is of
course, now that I've shown you that we
can actually see a pattern in the brain
both that's temporal and spatially
specific, what actually happens when we
try to deconstruct some of those sound
patterns from the brain? And this just
gives you an example, again, in the
superior temporal gyrus where those sounds
are activating the brain and an example of
the spectrogram for a given sentence and
in this case it's, “In what eyes they
were,” and the last part of that figure
basically shows you that pattern across
different electrodes.
It's not all happening in the same
particular way, you have very specific
evoked responses that actually occur in
different parts of the superior temporal
gyrus. And I want to show you what happens
when you look at just one of those
electrodes and if you look at the neural
response of that one particular electrode
that's labeled e1, and you organize the
neural response by different phonemes.
Okay, you can actually see again on the
vertical axis starting with 'da,' 'ba,'
'ga,' 'pa,' 'ta,' 'ka,' you can see
that this electrode, those hundreds of
thousands of neurons that are under this
electrode are very selectively responsive
to this set of sounds that we call
plosives. It's not one phoneme but a
category and they share this feature that
we actually know linguistically to be
called plosive.
I can show you a series of other other
electrodes, electrode two has a very
different kind of sensitivity, it's
showing you that it really likes those
sounds 'sha,' 'za,' 'sa,' 'fa.' This
is in electrode that is again not tuned to
one phoneme but actually tuned to the
category of sibilant fricatives in
linguistic jargon. We have another
electrode, e3, that is selective to low
back vowels these 'ah,' based ones, other
one that is a little bit more selective to
high fronted vowels 'e,' and even another
electrode e5 that is corresponding to
nasal sounds. So this is a very low level
description, but it's actually the first
time we've ever seen in this kind of
principled way, obtained through a very
precise spatial and temporal recordings,
the ability to resolve phonetic feature
selectivity at single electrodes in the
human brain.
Now this is not enough, we need to really
address this issue of structure. That's
one of themes here. And are all of these
things just equally distributed as
features in the original. . . thinking
about these things you could have a binary
list of features. And it turns out that
features in and of themselves actually
have structure and have relationships with
one another. And so, what we did in order
to look at that structure in the brain, we
looked at hundreds of electrodes that were
recorded over a dozen patients and each
one of those columns actually corresponds
to one electrode in one particular
superior temporal gyrus in someone's
brain. And like I just showed you before,
the vertical axis is actually how they're
organized by different phonemes.
And what we did here was we used a
statistical method called hierarchical
clustering, and what hierarchical
clustering is used for is finding the
patterns in this data. And what the
hierarchical clustering showed us and
sorted this data was that in fact there is
indeed structure in the brain's responses
to human speech sounds and it looks like
this. So we've organized the hierarchical
clustering as a function of a single
electrode's, again a single column's,
selectivity to different phonemes but
we've also organized this clustering as a
population response across all of the
electrodes and looking at that selectivity
for different phonemes. So you have two
different axes that were actually looking
at the brain's large distributed response
to speech sounds. And we're using this
method which is what we call
'unsupervised,' meaning we're not telling
it any linguistic information or we're not
organizing the data, we're just saying
tell us how the brain is organizing this
information.
And what we see from this is that when we
actually look at where this information is
being organized, one of the biggest
divisions between different parts of the
different kinds of selectivity in the
brain are what we would call the
difference between consonants and vowels
are really actually between obstruents and
continuants in linguistic jargon. But
within those different categories, you
actually have sub-classification. So
within the consonants you actually have
subdivision between plosives and
fricatives. And between the sonorants you
actually have referencing for different
positions of the tongue: low back, low
front, high front different classes of
vowels and in fact nasal.
So basically this is telling you that
feature selectivity in the brain is
actually hierarchically structured. The
second thing is that instead of using
phonemes in order to organize the
responses, we actually use features. So as
an example of that term, dorsal actually
refers to the tongue position when it's a
fairly back like for 'ga,' 'ka' sounds.
And you can see that when we organize
things by features, you have a much
cleaner delineation. The electrode
responses seem to be much more tuned to
phonetic features shown below as they are
compared to when you plot them as
phonemes. Okay, so this essentially
disproves any idea that there is
individual phoneme representation in the
brain at least not one that's locally
encoded, but tells you that the brain is
organized by its sensitivity to phonetic
features.
Now relating it to a phonetic features is
the first step and it's one that's really
important because it's referencing the one
that we know about from linguistics and
the one that we know behaviorally. But how
do we connect this to the physical
stimulus that's actually coming through
our ears? And that's where we have to make
a linkage to actually something about the
sound properties.
Are these things truly abstract features
that are being picked up by the brain or
actually are they referencing specific
sound properties? And basically, the
answer is the latter is that what we're
actually seeing is sensitivity to
particular spectral temporal features. In
the top row, I am showing you basically,
when we look at the average tuning curves
the frequency versus time tuning curves
for each one of those different
classifications for plosive fricatives,
they're very similar to the acoustic
structure when you average those
particular phonemes in the brain.
So what these means is the tuning that we
are seeing that's corresponding to
phonetic features is in fact one that is
tuned to high order acoustic spectral
temporal ones. The brain is selecting
specific kind of acoustic information and
converting it into what we perceive as
phonetic. In the interest of time, I'm
going to sort of skip more in depth
information about vowels and plosives and
how those are specifically encoded. But in
summary, what we found is that there's
actually a multidimensional feature space
actually for speech sounds in the human
superior temporal gyrus and that this
feature space is organized in a way that
actually shows hierarchical structure. And
that, the hierarchical structure is very
strongly driven by the brain's, in
particular this auditory cortex,
sensitivity to acoustic differences which
are most signified actually in the manner
of articulation distinctions
linguistically. And what's interesting
about this is it actually does correlate
quite well with some known perceptual
behavior. And so, I would like to conclude
there and acknowledge some of the really
important people from my lab: post
doctoral fellow Nima Mesgarani who did
most of this work with one of our graduate
students Connie Cheung.
Thank you.
[applause]
♪ [music] ♪